Taking a video.
Keep it on.
Okay.
The plate
is okay.
If you have a big piece, you can remove it.
It would be the best if not.
So the string will just take it by itself.
Okay.
Yeah.
We can just use it all again without an issue.
Before closing, we need to wipe the tube.
Especially at the bottom.
Keep it just closed.
I might throw people.
We'll probably start throwing that away.
I think he does it.
okay hold the slug and check if the nozzle is clear if there is the right opening
through but this is still too hot to touch it so if the nozzle will be clogged we would need to remove it but then we need to take all these pieces out remove it but now it's still 150 degrees so
we need to wait if we figure out ventilation is it ventilated we still
need to wait it's
got more of a condensation or okay you
have to run the class and be
this one with it
This is the other switch.
Why do they put two of them three feet on the switch?
Okay.
Great.
130 degrees, but it's empty.
The water is really cold.
Okay.
Yeah.
Right.
Here.
You should keep the cooling until 100 degrees.
But if it's empty, it's so close, it's not going to foil the water.
The water will move freely when it heats up.
The main of the problem is if you will have a big chunk of material left in, because, for example, there is no pouring, it will keep all this energy, all the heat in.
So it will take a long time to cool down, and you need to keep the cooling all the time.
So right now, let's just leave it, leave it, it will cool down.
Then we can come in and...
to remove the stock and put the new material in it sounds great